got to talk to people about that beta
ray bill trending on Twitter all even
you know what I don't even know how to I
don't know how to respond to this beta
ray bill trending on Twitter this is
ridiculous man
sweetheart Mariah what the whole world
to see why you lay on the couch say
what's up she took a nap beta ray bill
is trending this is actually kind of
beast right it's like some kind of
beasts cuz baby okay here's me my beta
ray bill right like beta ray bill in
some ways is kind of this unsung hero of
Marvel and another way she's kind of
dumb right I mean it's cool so here's a
cool thing mothers they can make some
amazing stuff with beta ray bill right
here's a really good example there's
this story by Karen Gillan called beta
ray bill God hunter and I think it
starts in for issue number 337 no it
doesn't I think it includes stuff from
337 so here's deal beta ray bill was
originally the creation of Walt Simonson
right so back in story issue number 335
Walt Simonson took over and he was like
we're doing my thing right it's like
right off the bat like Thor ends up
coming across this guy named beta ray
bill where he really is a korbinite but
basically the korbinite ways and I think
Galactus was the one who destroyed the
world but Corbin I the the core behind
waster world have basically been ravaged
and destroyed they didn't really have a
home anymore
they're traveling across the cosmos so
Nick Fury is like moderate space doing
ever as he's doing and he sees this by
huge herd or whatever it is this huge
caravan of vessels that are passing by
earth and he's like one of the heck is
this so he's like Thor go check it out
before it gets there get to this huge
fight with beta ray bill I was just like
dude this is kind of nutso eventually
like beta ray bill overpowers Thor and
then takes his hammer and it's like oh
man Lee he's the first person to pick up
the hammer of Thor like ever ever like
reading about that I wasn't alive at the
time that it came out I remember reading
about that and it was kind of nuts he
was like there's this guy who can wield
a hammer of Thor like it's kind of crazy
but you think I'm not gonna look at the
letters pages people were freaking out
they were like dude holy cow man as does
nuts some folks were losing me because
they're like only Thor should be able to
wield his hammer and they were losing
their minds because they don't like
change but then other people were just
like this is awesome because new things
are better than old things that don't
change so it was it was it was badass to
see regardless of the circumstance
eventually I think Odin has Thor fight a
fight
beta ray bill to determine who it is
worthy and I think beta ray bill
thrashes in but ultimately beta ray bill
ends up getting Stormbreaker he is like
getting like his own hammer basically
and they went forward as a hero and it's
cool right there's like this Brotherhood
between him and for anyway so
fast-forward to like whenever and Kieron
Gillen writes God hunter right so Thor's
like sitting around one day or I'm I'm
sorry not for beta ray bill sitting
around one day and he's like you know
what like I'm gonna I'm gonna destroy
Galactus like I'm gonna kill Galactus
and it's like but like why though
because I mean I mean yeah sure I mean
he'd led to like the destruction of your
races home planet so I mean I guess well
person showed up and burned down your
house you probably want to kill him too
but at the same time it's like but I
mean it's like Galactus though so I mean
this isn't a guy that you beat with
punches right you're not gonna like run
upon him with Stormbreaker and just like
pummel him to death it'd be funny but
that's not how that works right I mean
it'd be kind I think it'd be hilarious
to see like beta ray bill show up and
just like just pummel Galactus to death
with his hammer just like beat on him
like a nail but that's not how that
works right so it's like okay anyway so
this whole thing goes down they read
bill is a find the location of Galactus
Galactus is like feeding on that like
getting rid of feed on this planet beta
ray bill blows it up and it's just like
damn son like he just the stories of
world he's like screw you man I'm gonna
wipe out this world so you can't feed on
it it's kind of nuts so anyway the
battle the battle goes on like image of
Galactus goes to like another planet
where this group called the the ethan's
or something like that it's like I ' th
am ethan i guess that's how you
pronounce it and in beta ray bill like
targets the war by like releasing this
plague you know and like there's all
kinds of crazy stuff that goes on but
it's nuts right like there's one point
in the story where beta ray bill isn't
worthy anymore and he can't lift
Stormbreaker and it's just like damn so
I like it
Dubey ray those kind of nuts but he's
kind of cool here's the question here's
a question you have to ask if beta ray
bill is gonna be in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
how's all that gonna play out right it's
a perfect way to introduce Galactus into
the MCU right because I like the fan
theory somebody on reddit came up with
it wasn't me
I kind of wish I had but somebody came
up with this really good theory where
they said that Galactus actually not
Galactus when Thanos blinked out half
the life in the universe because he's
not an idiot and because like it
wouldn't like the plot end of itself
didn't make sense right that's something
I never understood about about infinity
war right Galactus or if Thanos is like
I'm gonna wipe out half a life in the
universe so ok Thanos well what about
like what are we gonna do in a hundred
years when like half the life comes back
then like are you gonna wipe it out
again like what how you gonna fix this
massive plot hole that nobody thought
about in infinity war because everybody
was obsessed with how good the movie was
um like the theory is that like familes
basically critical actives and Galactus
is gonna like basically continue the
campaign of like consuming worlds and so
on and so forth it's an awesome theory
it definitely fills in that giant
pothole that was left in by the writers
but um nonetheless uh it'd be a great
way to introduce him right like the
korbinites were a race that are out
there now and like beta ray bills
homeworld was destroyed by Galactus and
now like he's out on a quest for revenge
or something like that or for just
discovers him you know and I they get
into a huge fight but I don't know how
you do it I don't really care how you do
it what I do know is the Marvel
Cinematic Universe needs beta ray bill
like you need any beta ray bill in there
right because here's the thing
watching Avengers age of Ultron I think
they screwed the pooch when they let
vision pick up the hammer of Thor cuz
it's like who cares his vision he's an
Android nice tux like vision visions
okay but like the only thing he ever
really did that was significant you only
ever did two significant things three
significant things in Marvel Comics
right the first thing he did was turn on
Ultron the second thing he did was have
kids with Scarlet Witch I mean not how
that happens and the third thing he did
was like lose his identity and just go
back to being like a regular Android
right like visions not that great and so
like like in the movies when they're
like we're gonna have him lift the
hammer for it's like but why though Joss
Whedon like why would you do that
because it's time to dump like I think
it would've made more sense of Captain
America had been the first one to wield
it right because that was obviously a
smaller I don't sit in the movie theater
when Captain America lifted the hammer
of Thor
and it was nuts right like like like
literally a Thanos was like get ready to
kill for and it's like all dude fat
Thor's gonna die like this this sucks
man you know I was like and then like
adding know where the hair just like
Punk's conks panels over the head and I
was like oh my god no they didn't like
like somebody goes to pick up and I'm
like oh my god no they didn't know they
didn't man and like everybody in the
theater was like no leaning over that
sweetheart
Captain America picked up the hammer of
Thor man I [ __ ] was lit it was it was
amazing that giggles lift the hammer up
it's always slow motion like they knew
what they were doing it's on slow motion
and I was like all dude no way no way
bad and then like like the hammer goes
flying it's his phantom I ever come
summon him back a catheter he's like Oh
Rick James [ __ ] like it was amazing I
was that's what he should have said
honestly like every time he hits a nose
he should have been like Rick James
James that just like just do that it was
something it was amazing I'm sorry from
so excited people but it was an exciting
moment in the movie run I'm talking
about beta ray bill anymore it was an
exciting moment in the movie even now I
go back because I know you guys do the
same thing I go back and watch the video
on YouTube right cuz I'm just like
alright
it's pretty amazing but nonetheless for
beta ray bill in the MCU look here's the
thing
beta ray bill was one of these guys
where he shared a kind of camaraderie
and I kind of Brotherhood with for that
nobody else really had right it was it
was like like for for example some in
the help of beta ray bill during
Ragnarok right and like you get these
small things here in there and that's
kind of what you need is this guy who
was able to lift the hammer for he was
able to talents Thor in an in a literal
fight and and take the hammer from him
the problem with that is if you do that
now they kind of lost his impact and
that's all I always advocated the idea
that that I loved Captain America
lifting the hammer of Thor and Avengers
endgame but I always kind of felt like
beta ray bill should do it right because
it would really like to throw like
people were just doing who the hell is
this guy they can just lift the hammer
of Thor like one of the other guys one
of the other people doing it it's kind
of obvious Captain America doing it
vision
doing it I gas knows it's whatever and I
guess maybe Captain America lifting at
first but beta ray bill doing it would
just make his character significant but
he's also made him significant the
comics right he was least the first
person ever to pick up the hammer of
Thor that wasn't Thor like nobody had
ever done that before so it was it was a
crazy moment
um but regardless of how they slice it
beta ray bill needs to be done in a way
to where he's he's a warrior like like
Thor right I mean he's a protector of
his people that's how they first met he
was kind of like their protector that
was there to make sure the korbinites
you know if anybody showed up trying to
cause him problems beta ray bill would
like lay that lay to him he'd lay the
hammer down like this must be that kind
of guy right so I don't know I mean it's
curious to see how they're gonna do it
but again it's just a rumor at this
point right like nobody knows for
certain if that's what's gonna happen
with beta ray bill in the MC like nobody
even knows if he's actually gonna play
that guy I mean if I'm being honest
there's other characters I would love to
see in the MCU besides beta ray bill do
like a man god
oh let me tell you something man dude
let me tell you something man their Madi
God versus man God is a hoss right I do
here's that here's the thing man man God
like really even know his real origin
right like all we know it's just like
Odin did something and pistol and
basically wiped out a whole race and
slide their collective anger and rage
coalesced into like a singular being do
when man God shows up his curtains do
just drapes
mangog words like the only person that
Odin was ever afraid of right like
that's the way it's always been in
Marvel Comics man God shows up in Odin
shits his pants and it's just do it
always went that way and like that's
kind of what you need right like hello
how about like here's the thing hello
like shattering a hammer of four okay
cool like that's nice and pretty and
everything but like man God were just
like lay waste to a scar like it would
do won't even be there like do you would
like Thor we get crushed and not even by
a little bit like everybody was the
human deity he wouldn't stand a chance
in the first place but that's what I'm
saying like you're giving some dr.
strange villains like zom do here's the
thing there's one point like homage for
Doctor Strange it's like dude if zombie
ever shows up in our universe at full
power everyone's gonna die
like literally everyone's gonna die it
took the Living Tribunal to lock the
somme away he was just that damn power
for these zombies nuts he was you're
like this crazy looking at they may like
locked his hands up so he can't like use
magical power or anything he's like this
crazy-looking demon entity but like he's
super powerful but here's the thing like
I want to say Christian Bale play man
gosh that's what I want to see Thor
loved and thunder I want to see that
because like man God shows up it man you
guys think Bannos what the infinity all
and was impressive
then he's nothing compared to man god
man gods like this indestructible
immutable force of destruction right
he's just rage incarnate it's so amazing
like it's absolutely awesome anyway
Oh beta ray bill in the MCU is probably
gonna be cool I don't know it depends on
how they do it the Marvel Cinematic
Universe hasn't failed yet and so I
guess we'll just see we'll see what
happens what do we what baby film yet oh
okay I thought you were like coming in
but like that no that's what you were
gonna say but uh I'm excited I'm very
excited people let me know in the
comment section what you guys think and
yeah I will catch you all later Bruce